we have kimberly guilfoyle here who has
tried these types of cases you're gonna
explain this all to us but as I
understand it the real determining
factor was this idea of the other crimes
evidence and allowing other people to
come in and talk about prosecutors when
we use that kind of evidence in cases
called prior bad acts I so sort of like
the colloquial terminology and what it
is it's evidence of other people coming
forward to say that the defendant acted
in a way similar with them in terms of
like modus operandi the way that they
behaved in terms of a Bill Cosby in this
case they had to look for other
instances of victims and witnesses to
come forward to be very similar in
nature to this particular case and with
this victim alleged happened to her
which is a pattern and practice of
drugging for the purposes of committing
a sexual assault and in this case it was
alleged that benadryl was used to try to
put her out under it and it makes it
very difficult because when you're in a
case like this and somebody does this
you prey on another individual you use
something like that so because they
won't be able to really recall recollect
or be able to testify against you or
perhaps even identify when you hear of
cases and goofing at clubs etc it's
particularly heinous because you're
picking on a vulnerable victim to do
that in the hopes that they won't be
able to identify you in the hopes you'll
be able to do it again so that you can
prey on more victims and one of the
things in this case Bill Cosby will I be
identified and assessed as a sexual
predator they'll do an assessment and
present that to the judge at the time so
all those other pieces of evidence and
information that came forward they're
gonna put that forward to determine
whether or not he should be categorized
like that and of course register as a
sex offender at 80 years old at 80 years
old
years later my other question for you
and then I'll take it around the table
is when his lawyers say that they're
definitely going to appeal do you think
that that that they would try to appeal
on the grounds about this judge in his
discretion of allowing this evidence in
yes because you have a big gap pretrial
a hearing and you brief the matter to
say this is who we want to bring in and
they tried to bring in some 14 women to
come forward and the judge said well I
will allow these five because they are
probative verses too prejudicial to the
defendant because you really have to
balance that
because it's really ripe for a peel for
someone to bring that forward but this
has been something that as prosecutors
that I've done as you know prosecuting
sexual assault cases really fought hard
to get this to be evidence on the books
because it is so compelling in a case
like this where you didn't have you know
DNA or you didn't have a precision eye
witness there to say what happened to
her it's her word against his
that's why this other evidence is
compelling to say wait a second
someone's willing to take the stand take
an oath and tell you that the same type
of thing happened to them some of these
women were precluded from having justice
in their individual case because of the
statute of limitations has run but they
were still there to tell the truth and
subject to cross-examination that will
be the linchpin of meza rose appeal
which will probably take about two years
before that comes to light right you
were earlier today you were reminding
people just one more and everybody's
like that not going to jail in a couple
of weeks now and he's out he's out on
bail now pretty much sustained this is a
house they took away his passport
because they say it could be a flight
risk when you think of people like Roman
Polanski or you think Harvey Weinstein
when you have someone of means in
recourse that can charter a private jet
and take off and never be heard from
again
the judge made sure that wasn't gonna
happen in this case I wanna turn to you
for either a comment or a question for
Kimberly no I mean I you know so Cosby
someone I know pretty well and you know
to me Cosby his guilt was less in
question because he's someone who had
admitted that he was buying quaaludes
now an illegal drug for the purpose of
party and to give them to women and then
the question was whether or not that
kind of thing would be allowed and it
was allowed and in both trials that were
heard the difference in this one as
Kimberly was saying is that you had the
additional testimony that created it for
the jury the impression of a pattern of
abusive behavior and I think that
whereas there was an attempt to
undermine andrea constand the principled
person here charging cosby as someone
who was a con artist in the words of mr.
Cosby's defense attorney who was just
simply trying to make money off a very
rich famous man here came people who
said you know what I was just hoping
that he was going to
a father figure that he was going to
help me with my career I did not
understand that this was what he was
after and impossibly one of the most
chilling moments from the trial there
was a young woman who was 17 at the time
her name was chillin Lasha
and she says in open court you remember
me don't you mr. Cosby and it just it
was like oh my god you know she was 17
at the time and here she is now staring
him in the face and saying that's pretty
compelling if you're sitting there as a
juror and to say you know what is she
getting out she is no con artists in
addition remember Cosby had paid three
million dollars to constan in a civil
case so to some extent he had admitted
some culpability on that level but I
don't I just want to close on this
thought Dana which is you know he was
America's dad as you said in the opening
and the reason I know him so well is I
was writing a book about the fact that
he was saying to the black community hey
you know what there are different ways
to look at social progress and what's
going on our community why aren't we
taking a stand against the drug dealers
why aren't we saying something about
holding black families together why
don't we say something about our
responsibility in terms of high rates of
violent crime and it was so interesting
that the judge in the first case that
maybe before the first day said I want
to allow in all this evidence about
Cosby because he thinks he's such a
moralist he's he's lecturing other
people
so let's if his if he said in that
position he was buying quaaludes let it
be public for the big moralist boy it
came back to bite him big time
Greg had a question for Kimberly or if
you wanted to talk about anything in
particular well I guess everybody's kind
of covered the angles that you'd expect
I mean if I hear the phrase America's
dad again you know we get it it's a
surprise but remember these are
characters fiction fictitious characters
there are real people that play those
roles and they're sometimes they're just
not good people but I think we're all we
always kind of go well okay we're so
surprised but if you look around in
history and you look at a lot of
entertainers a lot of them do play
wholesome characters there was a Jimmy
Savile and in England who
was a big entertainer of children and
turned out he was disgusting molester I
Mike I have a side question that I'm
just curious what happens to the Cosby
Show
something that was probably one of the
most successful shows ever in
syndication you know it's like when you
watch The Naked Gun and OJ's in it you
can't really watch it the way you used
to watch it so when you watch The Cosby
Show when you're looking at it it
changes the way you look at something
and I wonder if that's it's the show
that kind of just goes away I'm not wild
Jesse about taking jury verdicts as
political statements because I think
jury verdicts are based on evidence of a
crime but there it's sort of inevitable
today that that's what happened
if you look at it in the context of the
me2 movement greg has always talked
about the the stratosphere of guilt it's
very clear that Bill Cosby is on the far
end of that stratosphere he's in higher
v-line weinstein situation because as
you said the predatory type behavior the
quaaludes and he was mixing the
quaaludes with alcohol in a grooming
process and over a pattern over the
course of I think since the 1960s it's
actually still pending a civil lawsuit
and I think Los Angeles County at the
Playboy Mansion where he allegedly
molested a teenage girl there at the
Playboy Mansion so that's still pending
so you know he's he's looking at at a
pretty tough next couple years when you
see someone that started out I mean as a
kid it's kind of bewildering because I
grew up with Cosby and you see all these
other talented people with these dark
sides and you don't really know how to
reconcile that but this guy really
deserves it I believe he starts with Fat
Albert and then you have mr. Huxtable at
one point he was making four million
dollars in episode with The Cosby Show a
huge crossover appeal racially
commercial appeal you know you had the
pudding coca-cola a lot of endorsement
deals at one point he was worth 400
million dollars and when Hannibal Buress
the comic did a little stand-up routine
in Philadelphia and joked that he was
rapist it all came crashing down and at
one point I think almost six
see women came forward since the 1960s
and said he did something to them and
you have TV land
pull the syndication deal yet NBC pull
out of their deal and the money dried up
the tour dates collapsed and now he's
probably gonna rot in jail or die in
jail and it's just a sad ending to the
legacy but at the same time you just
really want to pour your heart out to
all the women who were victims of this
man and I guess they had their day in
court and justice was served they want
me to tease but I did want to ask you
what you could expect at a sentencing
hearing okay so it's a sentencing
hearing they're gonna do the assessment
mr. Cosby and really do a deep dive into
his back they're gonna do it like
background social psychological
assessment and the defense will be able
to present witnesses or evidence on his
behalf and you'll also hear from victim
impact statements about what they did to
him and similar to the Gymnastics case
with dr. Larry Nasser and going forwards
out that we actually saw the women come
forward mckayla maroney who I did an
event with Rison was one of the women
that testified so and also what I think
is important here he should have to pay
not for just like the the crimes and
that he committed
but for the cost of the prosecution and
he made light of the three and a half
million is nothing so the prosecution in
this case is going to be asking for the
defendant to reimburse the state for the
price of prosecuting this case which was
quite extensive all right Thank You
Kimberly for the expertise